we have the story from the post
millennial newly appointed special
counsel David Weiss moves to drop
Hunter's plea deal Weiss drop the plea
deal that had been in the works with
Hunters Hunter Biden in Delaware over
tax crimes and a gun charge now I'm not
saying that uh he's going to get
punished as he he's going to face
accountability but I believe because of
the tremendous pressure that we have
placed covering the story and talking
about Biden's uh Hunter Biden's plea
deal they are now forced to actually
pursue some kind of real charges against
Hunter Biden granted I don't think he's
gonna get the charges he should get it's
still probably gonna be a slap on the
wrist but he's not getting that
sweetheart perfect immunity deal judge
wouldn't wouldn't fall for it the public
hears about it there's a there's a big
eruption and now they're forced to be
like okay we've actually got to charge
this guy for the crimes he's doing so I
do think it's fair to say pressure
forces them to make that move they know
there's a boundary they can't cross and
that's where we need to be if the issue
is we're playing a game a board game and
they keep cheating and making up fake
rules we just need to eventually say no
you can't do that move our piece back to
where it's supposed to be and force them
to acknowledge they're gonna have to
play by the rules too I think if we keep
this pressure up we look at Bud Light we
look at sound of Freedom we look at
Hunter losing his plea deal we can see
that the pressure is on and it does work
yeah I I totally agree with what you're
saying about
um about forcing them to essentially
play by the rules that we want to
establish because they've been
essentially making the rules up as they
go which is something that I've been
kind of harping on recently like just
the whole philosophy thing if the the
people that are on the left tend not to
have a philosophy that you know believes
that engaging uh good faith is actually
the proper course of action if you don't
have uh you know people that want to
engage with we want to engage with you
in good faith and you can't make a you
know you can't actually argue a position
and come to an agreement it's all just a
power game so I think that that's it
probably what you got to do I mean I see
the David Weiss thing as more of a
performative thing I mean this guy you
know it seems like he's gonna give what
Hunter Biden off the hook
um without you know you know obviously a
slap on the wrist wrist as you said I
mean he was gonna get right right well
he's a Republican so they you know it's
like the same exact uh Playbook as like
the Robert Mueller investigation they
try to you know pretend that this guy is
impartial that he's respected by both
sides of the aisle you know this guy's
an institutionalist and so forth so um
you know that's that's how I see it I
get that but they were trying to give
Hunter Biden blanket immunity right that
got pulled off the table they're
probably now groaning being like damn it
didn't work okay well we'll get our guy
in there and we'll claim he's a
Republican and then they're still gonna
have to give Hunter Biden something
worse than he was going to get my point
is only is I don't think we've won but
we've certainly taken some territory
enforcing them to acknowledge like hey
that deal was bad they tried to pull a
fast one now they're gonna try and still
pull some kind of fast one but they've
lost ground so that's still good you
gotta take small victories where you can
I think first of all I don't think he
should be I gotta pass 100 body should
not have been charged for the gun thing
like second amendment rights they're
saying he lied on a form or whatever Nah
if he was if you're if you're under the
influence you shouldn't be able to be
carrying a weapon if you're not you have
sound mind you should be able to buy one
I don't like that charge at all lying on
his tax forms
I also kind of don't like Texas so I
will only say this
the only issue is they'll come after a
regular American for those charges
tenfold right and we need to have
equality under equality under the law
and and accountability
I want Hunter Biden to face some serious
charges but more importantly
I see we've gained a couple inches here
you know we've we've moved forward a
little bit we've Advanced the line
that's good not perfect what we really
need to see and we need intensive
pressure on is his illicit business
dealings and serving as a proxy for his
dad and influence peddling but that's
gonna have to come from Congress and
they seem to be sitting on their hands
yeah I think so I I I I mean yeah it's a
step in the right direction and Congress
will have to act it will have to do much
more than it's already done I mean at
this point Congress I mean not to change
the subject here but they should have
subpoenaed out Alvin Bragg the D.A um
leading this uh indictment against
Donald Trump in New York should've uh
subpoenaed all these uh prosecutors
going out against Donald Trump by now I
don't know why they have not
um you know here in this case at least
David Weiss
um is at least uh we know for Jack Smith
is a total political hack I mean his
wife was
um you know donated thousands of dollars
to Joe Biden the 2020 presidential
campaign
um she worked for a film company that
had uh Financial ties allegedly to
George Soro so I mean you know at least
in this case you know they try to
pretend like this guy is uh somewhat
more you know nonpartisan here but then
again you know I do think we have to
raise the bar we have to raise the
standard much higher and demand much
more from our Congressman so what would
you like to see happen to Hunter Biden
um well I mean Tim mentioned you know
these charges
that a normal American probably
um would get off the hook here or or a
normal American we basically have to get
to the business dealings with barisma
with what we're seeing with the Tucker
Carlson uh interview of this past week
um between David Archer and basically
the connection there that you know Joe
Biden was
um
you know meeting with these people when
you know taking it while he was he
should have been meeting with the
Chinese uh prime minister he was taking
meetings with uh Hunter Biden and his
company and so on and so forth so that's
the Crux of the issue but I I'm more my
perspective on this is at least you know
they're getting him for something I mean
we know what the crime is we know what
the uh problem is we know what
um fraud he this guy really committed
against the United States but at the
very least they're going after him for
something and I think
um you know we should be satisfied with
that
um from that Vantage Point
um but then again the pressure has to be
much higher I think from our elected
lawmakers we should bring these people
we should bring David Weiss you know
subpoena him potentially we should
question him interrogate him we should
demand more from our government I mean
this guy was already serving in
government which is in violation of
federal law he should not we should not
a special counsel should not be someone
with ties already to the federal
government
um with ties to the Deep State we should
truly select someone outside of the
government which we have not done here
so that's something that we should be
looking at for this specific case here
but again you know the pressure needs to
be put on these people because as we've
seen they'll get they'll get away with
doing anything you know they'll try to
impeach their major political opponent
they'll try to get Donald Trump Behind
Bars and they're going to stop at
nothing
um you know to accomplish that goal that
is their end objective so that's up to
us the American people to put the
pressure on them and keep them hold
their feet to the fire because if we
don't no one else will going back I had
a question off topic going back since
you're pretty knowledgeable could Donald
Trump have pardoned the January Sixers
I that's something that he should do and
I think that's something that he's
looking at very strongly right now and
if he obviously is re-elected in 24 he
yeah because I was wondering did he have
the power while he was in office to
still do that some people question did
why didn't he do that that's why I was I
I mean it's difficult I mean he he was
being impeached at the time we tend to
forget that he was impeached once he
left office so there's so much going on
at the time
um for Donald Trump that I think that
question there wasn't enough time to
explore it
um the argument is that he didn't know
what was going on he didn't some people
he said this is actually a really great
answer he said that uh some of these
people did bad things they were violent
and they were committing crimes and you
know how do you have enough time with
two weeks to go through all this and
figure out you know who they're charging
and what they're charging them with and
the people who were charged and arrested
many of them were actively violent they
went after the fact when Trump is no
longer president after a lot of the
people who were walking around confused
there's no way Trump would be able to I
mean there's thousands of people in DC
there's no way he's going to be able to
figure out who accidentally walked on
the lawn and would later be charged with
very serious crimes you've got people uh
Brandon strach didn't even go in the
building and they and they got him
criminally charged so
I think it's unfortunate Trump maybe
could have done something but uh it's a
rock and a hard place because
hundreds of thousands of people I think
were down there that day at his rally
and then at the rally outside of the uh
there was a peaceful permitted rally
outside of the capital
800 or so people went inside
they're now charging not only the people
who went inside but even people who are
on the capitol grounds with being on
restricted grounds or something like
this there's no way for Trump to have
pardon those guys there's too many names
too many people he doesn't know what
they're going to charge you can you can
if Trump had a list of everybody went
there if he made a website and said send
me your name right now and I will pardon
you that maybe would work but then what
right he's gonna go through every single
name one guy punched a cop you don't
want to Pardon that guy he had two weeks
between January 6th and January 20th and
you may forget they were trying to oust
him from office before January 20th um
in in January of 2021 there there was a
movement to get him pushed out of the
White House like day after January 6th
so he had so much going on at that point
in time obviously this is a serious
issue and now if he does get reelected
um you know he uh this is something that
he would do but
um you know at the time it was just he
needs like a task force right yeah is
that going through all the names right
and I mean it's actually really simple
you know now do files Trump I would say
give me a list of every misdemeanor
charge and they are pardoned every
single one no matter what well every
charge should have been a misty not the
guys were fighting cops yeah like if
there were a lot of people who stormed
the barricades and were actively
fighting with cops like nah dude you
Riot you get charged with chart with
those charges some of those guys
probably were just misdemeanors like a
guy who's on the front line screaming
and yelling and like pushes a cop
probably didn't get a felony
but if you're one of the guys who was
like throwing stuff I mean there was a
fire extinguisher that was thrown they
lied and claimed it killed a cop didn't
but I mean yeah I don't know how I feel
about pardoning people who are actively
fighting with with cops you know what I
mean thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time